senior Trump advisor Stephen Miller went
on TV on Sunday he did a round of
interviews basically channeling the
dictatorial perspective the likes of
which we would expect to hear from
someone like North Korean dictator Kim
jong-un the president has all the power
the president will not be questioned
period truly disturbing and reminiscent
of despotism I get the kids out of the
room before this clip I'm about to play
for you this is very disturbing and
scary for anybody that believes in
concepts like democracy checks and
balances etc brace yourself
strap in folks do you feel like you and
your staff there that you're in control
of events at the White House I think to
say that we're in control would be a
substantial understatement
we have equal branches of government in
this country the judiciary is not
supreme there's no such thing as
judicial supremacy what the judges did
both of the ninth end of the district
level was to take power for themselves
that belong squarely in the hands of the
President of the United States Stephen
the three judges say you're flat wrong
no the three judges made a broad
overreaching statement this is an
ideological disagreement between those
who believe we should have borders and
should have controls and those who
believe there should be no borders and
no controls this is a judicial
usurpation of power the end result of
this though is that our opponents the
media and the whole world will soon see
as we begin to take further actions that
the powers of the President to protect
our country are very substantial and
will not be questioned and the bottom
line is the president's powers in this
area represent the apex of executive
authority we will have unquestioned
military strength beyond anything
anybody can imagine we have a president
who is done more in three weeks than
most presidents have done in an entire
administration saying that we stand with
our ally having the two men appear on
camera worldwide to all of planet Earth
was the statement that will be
understood very well by North Korea I'm
not going to make a comment on that I
don't have any information on it I do
want to say that Sean Spicer as always
is a hundred percent correct and that
what he said
is true and important and I agree with
it so then you are making a comment on
it I'm not going to make any new comment
it is a fact and you will not deny it
but there are massive numbers of
non-citizens in this country who are
registered to vote that is a scandal we
should stop the presses that's the story
we should be talking about and I'm
prepared to go on any show anywhere any
time and repeat it and say the president
of united states is correct 100% first
instinct pat is this a character that
this guy's playing or is he actually an
unbridled lunatic I think it's a
character immediately what stood out to
you the most the biggest thing for me
was that Sean Spicer is correct 100% of
the time yeah I believe that I actually
think Steven Miller is completely out of
his mind I think that he is unhinged in
a way that we have rarely seen before
Joe Scarborough and Mika Brzezinski on
MSNBC they were they actually seemed to
be literally at a loss for words after
seeing this that's of White House
adviser right not even funny
I can't even oh my god can we hold off
so much work is money or a thought it's
much worse Wow 100% correct what happens
incorrect it is a fact and you will not
deny the fact it was actually a lie and
then again he learned this I guess in an
autocracy for young young political gain
you want me not what I saw when he said
what they did the attitude of the
administration the great leaders wisdom
will not be questioned publicly period
this tells us so much about why the
administration would be so upset about
Saturday Night Live parodies right and
this rant should worry everybody it's
not just Democrats or liberals or
whatever the administration is totally
unconcerned with the truth but that lack
of concern with the truth is being
combined with a complete and utter
disregard for the separation of powers
and Donald Trump went at to praise
Stephen Miller after these insane
appearances on Twitter saying
congratulations Stephen Miller on
representing me this morning on the
various Sunday morning shows great job
I've not seen anything like this yeah
absolutely not and I mean Stephen
Stephen Miller is only 31 years old yep
which sounds a little young to be the
senior policy advisor president so maybe
he feels like he has to prove himself
yeah if that means lying or sounding
like an authoritarian he's willing to do
it he needs to go out there and appear
to be a lawyer
loyal soldier to Trump and that's
exactly the impression that he gave
you'd think that after eight years from
Republicans screaming about how Obama's
a dictator that they see Stephen Miller
show up and say effectively the
president will not be questioned and all
of his associates are 100% right period
no one in the Obama administration ever
showed up on national TV and ranted in
this fifth tutorial way but imagine if
someone had do you have any idea what
would have happened if Valerie Jarrett
an Obama advisor for example went on
national TV and said things like this it
would be wall-to-wall coverage on all
right wing media if Obama or anybody
associated with them had even hinted at
the idea that quote the president's
power will be unquestioned it would have
been scandal because of its
authoritarian dictatorial nature but
when it's Trump's guy Wow
bright young guy how Pat doing a hell of
a job it also just doesn't make any
sense I mean we have three equal
branches of government in this country
and judicial review is a thing they
struck down Donald Trump's travel and
Refugee ban and they were completely in
their authority to do that oh yeah but I
mean you're operating at the facts level
and that I'm that debt has a it's funny
but that is no bearing whatsoever on
what people like Kellyanne Conway Sean
Spicer and Stephen Miller are going to
say discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
read it that's re d di t Gamefly is sort
of like netflix for video games they
have over 8,000 new and classic games
for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you
for one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low use price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s